hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to be
talking about the life cycle of the
trochocatrium dendrobatidis also known
as the kytrid fungus
before we launch into it i want to tell
you about
the free study notes so you can check
out the link in the description below to
get a picture it's free of a pdf of the
final board so once i filled in all of
the blanks you can access that and print
it and it is a great tool those free
study notes so be sure to check those
out and of course don't forget to
subscribe
uh let's start talking now about this
life cycle this is for petrochokitrium
dendrobatedus
often this is referred to as the chitrid
fungus of course it's not the only
ketrad fungus but it is very well known
because of what it's been doing to
global populations of amphibians
so let's go ahead and get started a
little bit of information before we jump
into the life cycle this is a fungal
pathogen
okay so the choco kitrium
diphthrobatidus is a fungus
and it has spread around the world like
it's literally been found on every
continent but antarctica where it's too
cold for it to survive
so it's a global pathogen it's often
been spread due to human activities for
example
xenopus lavish the afro the south
african clawed frog was shipped
worldwide a few decades ago because it
was actually being used in early
pregnancy tests and it was likely taking
this fungal pathogen around the world
with it and there are many other human
activities that can spread this fungus
around i actually studied the
trochocatrium dendrobatist when i was in
graduate school um it was the subject of
my phd
which is in microbiology and immunology
and um when i was out in the field if i
was going into like a clean area i
actually had to
this is when i was doing some field work
in panama i had to like step
in a tray of bleach water
for a while to make sure that any of
this fungus that was on my boots that i
picked up in the field was killed before
we entered the area
at a wildlife sanctuary where amphibians
were being housed because of course this
is a fungal pathogen of amphibians i
think i forgot to say that earlier so it
causes a disease
called catridiomycosis
tritiomycosis i'm kind of running out of
room there of course any mycosis is a
disease caused by a fungus and this is a
fungal disease caused by in particular
this patroco ketrium right that ketrid
fungus
there are some closely related species
like there's the trochochetrion
salamander borons which is again related
and has a similar life cycle
but in particular this first one um that
was that was discovered petrochetrium
dendrites dendrobates
can infect over 300 known species of
amphibians so we're talking lots of
frogs lots of toads lots of salamanders
cecilians
and probably more species than even we
know that it can infect and it has
contributed to approximately 100
amphibian
extinctions
i'm going to put a sad face here and
that really doesn't even begin to cover
it i read a paper
published in 2019
indicating that it had contributed to
approximately 90 extinctions
known by those authors at that time and
of course it's been a few years since
then
and so this number keeps going up
now let's kind of jump into the major
purpose of this video which is the life
cycle of this pathogen the life cycle
duration is about
four to five days
at 22 degrees celsius
now because it was the subject of my
graduate work i grew this stuff in
culture all the time i had
little culture flasks full of growth
media
and fungus growing in it kind of all the
time and we were done with it we had to
bleach it
so
let's start up here okay so i'm going to
go through basically four stages
the zospor the phthalus the zos
barangium and then basically the
discharge step
so we'll start right here this shows
these aquatic so these are
living in aquatic environments that's
where you're going to find this pathogen
it is motol okay motile meaning it can
move
and this particular stage is called a
zospore
so aquatic motor zospores disperse
actually they've been given off by azo
sporangium we'll get to that at the end
and colonize host skin
this right here is pointing to
a flagellum so that is what makes them
modal they are able to swim with the
movement of a flagellum
then the zoospores once they find
some host skin to land on this would be
amphibian skin
the zospores will insist
so insisting means they resorb the
flagellum
and develop a foul wall
so the zoospores they um
resorb their flagella they develop a
cell wall that's called insisting or
insistent
and develop into the next life stage
which is called a phallus
now the plural of phthalates is phthali
so multiple of that phthalates life
stage would be called stalais
and they have
these
rhizoid
these structures called rhizoids so
these are kind of filamentous appendages
coming off that kind of help with like
attachment and even growing these in
culture when there is no host skin for
them to attach to you can still see
these rhizoids under a microscope
so then eventually the phthalates and
the phthalus is a little bit bigger than
the zospore the zospores are like two to
three microns and the phallus might be
like
five or six microns i'm trying to
remember that off the top of my head the
stylus will mature into an even larger
structure called a zosporangium
okay so matures into a zosporantium and
this is where new
zospores are formed so you see that
there is a cap
right there and so that cap it's like a
plug right it um seals that discharge
tube
and you've got the zoos force forming
inside what happens is you basically
have a lot of
a lot of dna synthesis in here you kind
of have something that looks like
multi-nucleated and then there are these
cleavage events that separate
those into the individual zoo spores
and then the kind of final stage of this
process is that once a cat dissolves
zoospores are released through one or
more
what are called discharge
papillae
or sometimes we just say discharge tubes
but the papillae
are the discharge tubes now i've drawn
ones here that have one
of those discharge tubes they look kind
of like urns but certainly when i was
studying this fungus i'd look at it
under a microscope
and i would regularly see
i'm gonna try to
kind of
draw this i would regularly see
something that looks like this right
full of zo spores it's also cool
because
um you know i could even sometimes see
again when using a microscope i could
see the zo spores you know when they're
at this stage where they're all in there
like actually starting to like wiggle
and move and and and move up through a
recently opened tube
um i've even seen them before with like
three discharge papillae so that can
happen as well
also not shown here but these things um
particularly when growing in culture can
form very large colonial structures
meaning a colony where you can have you
know ten
fifty a hundred of these
zosforangia remember zoe sporangium is
singular zosparangia is plural but you
could have very large numbers of them
all kind of clumps together
um rhizoids entangled
um
into these very complex kind of colonies
now
in red here i've drawn the host skin
surface because i want you to remember
that all of this is happening within the
context of amphibians skin
so the zoospores swim towards the skin
infect the cells insist and then um over
the course of a few days are going
through this process
and as the amphibian skin is shed
these zosporangia are going to get
closer and closer to the surface of the
skin
and their goal
really is for these papillae to be able
to just kind of protrude right out of
the epithelial cell at the surface of
the host's skin
so that these zoo spores aren't
necessarily being released like within
the epithelium of the current host but
are actually discharged out into the
remember aquatic environment where they
can swim with their flagellum
to swim and find another host to infect
so that is the batrachocatrium
dendrobates life cycle i have a playlist
a playlist that goes into a lot of
different life cycles if you're
interested in fungal life cycles in
particular i have a video on the life
cycle of
the fungus that causes histoplasmosis
and if you're interested in fungal
pathogens more generally or particularly
fungal pathogens that cause human
diseases i also have a video called
introduction to fungal pathogens that
focuses on those human fungal pathogens
don't forget to subscribe and don't
forget to get the link in the
description box below where you can get
a folder of free study notes including a
picture of this board with all of the
notes filled in so that will be it for
today thank you guys for watching
biology professor tell me in the
comments tell me tell me tell me you
know have you heard of the choco kitchen
dinner beta disc this kitchen fungus the
amphibian declines the extinctions um
you know it's something that i studied
for several years and i was getting my
phd and so if you think it's interesting
i'd love to
you know hear what you know about it and
what you think so i guess that will be
it for today thank you for watching
remember to subscribe bye